wenn sich der abend über die ewige stadt
senkt wächst der appetit der römer und
eine armee von lieferanten erobert die
nächtlichen straßen
leider werden sie genannt der 28 jährige
james usami ist einer von ihnen ein
zweirad ritter über stock und über stein
der verkehr in rom ist der reinste
horror
es gibt ja sehr viele autos und viele
halten sich nicht an die verkehrsregeln
dazu kommen die vielen schlaglöcher
deswegen ist es sehr gefährlich durch
rom zu fahren
[Musik]
durch den großstadtdschungel begleiten
wir james in die nacht seitdem coroner
lockdown ist der besuch der geliebten
trattoria oder pizzeria abends untersagt
davon profitieren die großen
lieferdienste
guten abend erst james am telefon
dekoriere ich bin schon vor der haustür
denn sie bitte runterkommen pasta pizza
und dolce vita auf rädern ak st james
musste in vorkasse gehen und ist
erleichtert als die kunden bar bezahlt
der erste auftrag geschafft in letzter
zeit bestellen wir ziemlich häufig ich
bin studentin und den ganzen tag zu
hause
ich kann nicht viel weg gehen obwohl ich
das gerne möchte abends bestelle ich
dann lieber etwas weil ich erlernen muss
carpe noctem nutze die nacht james hat
bereits den nächsten auftrag über die
app bekommen
also los geht's bei mir ist eine
bestellung reingekommen
die muss sich in der via vittorio
cologne abholen wohin müssen wir fahren
eine bestellung für 20 euro ich muss
schauen wo das restaurant ist
auch er kennt längst nicht jede ecke
obwohl james bereits vor vier jahren aus
nigeria nach rom gekommen ist jetzt muss
er sich beeilen das prinzip je mehr
lieferung er hat desto mehr wächst sein
punktekonto nach einem autounfall viele
aus und rutschte im ranking weit nach
unten wo die schönen seiten rom seit der
kaum einen blick übrig weil ich hier nur
93 punkte habe und heute donnerstag ist
haben sie mir nur zwei arbeitsstunden
gegeben dann am freitag zweieinhalb
stunden samstag vier stunden sonntag
zweieinhalb stunden das ist viel zu
wenig und genau das ist mein problem das
sich erfahrungsgemäß habe zeit ist geld
doch selbst wenn james pünktlich ist
eines kann er in dieser corona pandemie
nicht mitliefern das gemeinschaftsgefühl
die kontaktfreudigen römer leiden
besonders an den allabendlich
geschlossenen base und trattorien
mir fehlt es ins restaurant zu gehen
nach einem langen arbeitstag bräuchte
ich einen moment der entspannung um
abzuschalten und die restaurants in rom
vermissen am abend die kunden wo wir in
isola della pizza im stadtteil partie
nordkorea verordnung dürfen sie nur bis
18 uhr
der mittagstisch lohnt sich nur am
sonntag umsatz wird am abend gemacht mit
eigenem außer haus verkauf hält familie
pantalone den pizzaofen nur notdürftig
am laufen
wir haben 15 angestellte die wir
bezahlen müssen einige bekommen
kurzarbeitergeld aber das reicht nicht
während der woche ist das ein einziges
verlustgeschäft doch von den großen
lieferdiensten und digitalen apps hält
sie wenig es lohne sich für die kleinen
restaurants einfach nicht allein für die
anmeldung müssen sie drei bis
vierhundert euro zahlen und bis zu 35
prozent auf den gewinn
deshalb wird im restaurant dann nur noch
aufgeräumt bevor frau pantalone schweren
herzens ab schließt mit dem
mittagsgeschäft und dem abendlichen
außer haus verkauf halten wir uns etwas
über wasser sicher das gibt uns ein
bisschen motivation um weiterzumachen
aber insgesamt ist das wirklich sehr
hart sehr hart
kaum hat sie dicht gemacht beginnt auf
den straßen roms die zeit den ryder und
james sucht ein günstiges viertel mit
vielen restaurants eine poleposition im
gnadenlosen rennen um aufträge kunden
und system punkte
und ausgerechnet jetzt hat er eine
reifenpanne und freiwilliger boxenstopp
an der piazza venezia jede verzögerung
kostet zeit er fällt im ranking zurück
wird bei der auftragsvergabe weniger
berücksichtigt
also heute ich weiß auch nicht was ist
das erste mal dass ich auf der straße
einen platten habe aber so ist das leben
keiner weiß wann er sterben muss
allein auf roms straßen gibt es mehr als
8000 sogenannte leider die im virtuellen
netz der digitalen liefer portale hängen
deren algorithmen geben den takt
unerbittlich vor die situation der
reiter ist äußerst prekär klagen die
gewerkschaften die plattformen benutzen
einen mechanismus der dazu führt dass
möglichst viele reiter auf den straßen
unterwegs sind
sie sind abruf bereit um lieferungen zu
übernehmen wenn es dann weniger
bestellungen gibt dann bedeutet das für
jeden einzelnen rider weniger arbeit
james hatte sich das auch alles viel
schöner vorgestellt als er vor vier
jahren aus nigeria hierher kam
ich bin über das mittelmeer nach italien
gekommen
zuerst war ich auf sizilien
danach kam ich nach rom ins
flüchtlingslager und dort habe ich dann
alle dokumente bekommen die notwendig
waren um ein besseres leben zu beginnen
für viele migranten wir ihn hat sich
durch corona die situation zusätzlich
verschärft eine reihe job bringt james
pro monat 6 bis 7 100 euro ein
der nächste kunde lässt ihn wegen
coroner nicht nach oben zahlt online und
schickt aber den fahrstuhl zurück mit
fünf euro trinkgeld das einzige an
diesem abend die zusammenarbeit endet in
einer minute jetzt ist schluss ich war
dann nach hause
hoffen wir mal dass es morgen mehr
bestellungen gibt und dass sie mich mehr
arbeiten lassen
finito die app macht mit ihm schluss für
heute die nächtliche kälte kriecht empor
am kolosseum der antiken arena roms und
james wird morgen weiterkämpfen als sie
bei gladiator auf den straßen der ewigen
stadt
[Musik]